first job at pomegranate marinade for
the quail which have been cut in half
and flattened
so small aren't they small yeah it's
tiny so it's almost like a sort of nice
entrance into eating something slightly
gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt and pepper
and all spatchcock means is the rib cage
has been taken out and they're flattened
down and because the bird is so delicate
it's flattened to cook evenly
and
it really is a nice sort of light gamey
dense chicken flavor
so we're toaster spices when you think
of middle eastern food it's packed with
amazing flavors tablespoon of coriander
a teaspoon
of cumin
and a nice little seasoning
of salt so we toast them now
intensifying the flavor
when they start smoking lightly
that's a nice indication that they're
ready
okay
if you grind away so the best thing
there let's just stand up close today
thank you
oh look your tummy's out
i thought it was the quail tummy this
hand here
keeps it nice and firm
and you grind that into a nice powder
for belly please
smells so good doesn't it yeah
so to get that in
really go around the outside and that
grinds it up
i've gone around the pestle mortar
more times than you kiss boys
squeeze the garlic in next
a little glove
olive oil
okay then i want to pour six tablespoons
please
so that is pomegranate molasses so it's
like an aged parsley vinegar but really
reduced down give that a nice mix up
is it gonna be very sweet dad a little
taste
it's sweet but sour
yeah it is
it's so good though no
take
a nice spoon
put it inside the quail
you can even do this the night before
because you pop them in the fridge let
the quail marinate anywhere from half an
hour to overnight
for my ultimate middle eastern dessert
it's got to be baklava
start by melting butter in a pan
chop pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combine with caster sugar and lemon
zest
[Music]
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray
place half a sheet of filler pastry on
the
base brush well with melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix
repeat and press down between layers
[Music]
you're looking to create 30 to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut the baklava into bite-sized
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30 to 40 minutes
meanwhile make your delicious citrusy
syrup simply add water to a pan along
with caster sugar
and the zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar has fully dissolved
now to give the cloud a wonderful
sweetness remove from the oven and
whilst hot pour over the syrup so each
layer is gloriously sticky
leave the balcava to absorb the syrup
for at least 12 hours these delicious
sticky treats will keep for a week but
they're so moorish they'll be gone in a
flash the quails have marinated now
they're ready to cook
nice hot pan
pick up your quail
and skin side down first okay
[Music]
get all that nice color
and always open them up as well in the
pan
okay we'll get that skin crispy crispy
that's right
smell that pomegranate i can really
smell it smells so good you get all that
marinade in there
you know cook with it as well don't
waste it how long on average does it
take to cook could you go literally
12-15 minutes in the oven
a little touch of water
in
bring that up to the bowl
into the oven 180
so 12 to 15 minutes
okay
the final job before serving a herby
butter bean salad to go with my quail in
pomegranate molasses
now
one of the things that i
love about middle eastern cellars is the
sort of crunch
and the color as well butter beans
it's gonna be the base
of our salad
from there
little radishes
and sort of top
and tail them get them like that
and throw them in
there's nothing small and dainty in
there okay yeah so
with the spring onions
nice we're going to use the greens and
the whites i'm going to slice
along that way this time to get those
nice light shards okay yeah
now
the croutons
are made out of these little pita breads
just slice lengthways
in with the salad oh yes
so this salad is all about texture so
cucumber okay
and take out the seeds
how come you're taking the seeds out it
just makes the salad
very watery
like a shower okay
cucumber juice delicious i guess you go
yeah you got me going you really got me
going no no no oh yeah
i've got revision to be doing don't
worry this is far more important trust
me who needs exams where you can cook
for a living
you gave me with my exams it's fine it's
fine it's fine be a chef for a living
have a proper job don't take your things
out like that you'll be thumbless let's
go now
your cucumber in
from there
take your nice
vibrant tomatoes slice down
it almost looks like a greek salad as
those colors it resembles that that's
right and with the celery
like before yeah lengthways so we need
some mint and parsley
i want you sprinkling it in there and
really mix it through the herbs give it
that nice kind of freshness
but i want a bit of a bite in there now
i love pomegranate so
just carefully
open that up okay and then just dot them
on top so we've got a bit of fruitiness
now into the salad
for crunch simply cut up whole pita
breads fry in a really hot pan with
olive oil until wonderfully golden
crispy and irresistible
out
into a
sieve
[Music]
okay next a sprinkle of sumac
that's a dried fruit from middle east
the zest of a lemon
and the juice
then a drizzle of olive oil
and last but not least my crunchy pitter
croutons
croutons on oh they've gotten hard oh
just lift that up
and mix in your hands there nice and
jump just with fingertips there you go
so you just mix there you go it doesn't
crush anything it doesn't crush anything
but then let's just take
a little bean
wow
isn't that delicious mm-hmm
nice
now quail
it's got that really
sort of toasted almost like a sort of
light smells so good barbecue flavor
can't wait to try it
beef wow
just finely a bit of lemon zest it just
lightens everything up a little bit
and it goes so well with the pomegranate
now just
wow
that'll smell better than any boyfriend
you'll ever have oh my god
i beg to differ
okay good let's go
how delicious is that so delicious
[Music]
my middle eastern feast of quail with a
pomegranate molasses and butter bean
salad with batava to follow when dishes
are this aromatic and colorful there's
no wonder that middle eastern food is
always a hit
you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer
reinvented and marketed by pubs as a
plan was lunch in the 60s i'm now giving
it my 21st century take
like player ones with the most amazing
but super simple beer baked bread hearty
and full of flavor
for a really quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
salt is really important to bread it's
the first thing i do once i've cracked
it and smelled you want to smell that
salt baked throughout
beer in
about 250 mils of beer
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's going to work beautifully
give that a really good mix i'm looking
for the mixture to be quite wet if the
dough becomes too firm then it's going
to cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
whisk that is perfect
beautiful
this mix will work really well as one
large loaf but i want to make my plan
ones a little bit more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and i quite like having my own little
loaf
give the molds a really nice
lining with butter make sure
you butter the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture
sticking
tap out any excess
three quarters fill your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of rise
just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart into the
oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
[Applause]
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan was it's complete without
pickled onions
red onion is a lot sweeter less harsh
than a white onion the
early days of
plan ones you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that
make you almost cry when you're
crunching them i'm gonna lightly pickle
my
red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings a
little touch of salt a little sprinkle
of sugar and then a couple of cloves in
there that gives it a really nice sort
of perfume and sort of makes the
pickling slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red matches the red
onion so it goes hand in glove a couple
of tablespoons of vinegar
just give that a really good
mix
[Music]
to speed up the pickling process use a
weight to put pressure on the onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work their magic and it comes out with a
really nice light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century ploughmans i'm
creating an all-in-one salad and
bringing the traditional elements
together with a punchy dressing
a tablespoon of english mustard
a tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper
and finish off with white wine vinegar
and olive oil
[Music]
now generally
it's sort of three parts oil to one part
vinegar that's the sort of general base
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern
approach to player ones
for my player one salad i'm using a
mixture of robust and crunchy romaine
lettuce
and punchy watercress
if i was making a watercress soup i'd
use the stalks but the stalks are a
little bit bitter so i just grabbed them
like that pinch them and then twist
[Music]
very peppery
very hot but so juicy watercress in
your celery chop it nice and finely
it's the one thing that everybody leaves
is that stick of celery so
scatter it amongst the salad
a bit of um fun color from some sliced
radishes and sweetness from a thinly
sliced apple
whilst you're busy throwing your plum
and salad together do not forget about
your beer bread
before it comes out i'm going to glaze
the top with a little touch of milk
that'll put a really nice finish to the
bread back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plum ones
generally you'd see it as a ham or
cheddar or stilton flour ones it's hard
to dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate ploughman's i'm
adding all three
rear cheddar
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar just get them dancing on
top
the dressing
drizzle ran in circles
and then finally
our delicious lightly pickled onions
give them a good squeeze
look just dot the onions around
bread
it's ready
it's got that nice
yeasty smell
warm
crusty and delicious
there you go
that is my classic modern version
of a traditional stunning play almonds
wow
[Music]
my delicious all-in-one plan one salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
lightly fried my delicious lumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vitamins
good or even just big
normal plump tomatoes lay the tomatoes
on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned with salt sprinkle
over with some sugar
and the salt and sugar combine speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little time flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees c and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
peel the carrots
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette
the secret is keeping all grated the
same
put that into a sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it in the
pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg
and we'll see all that water that needs
to come out of there
if you didn't do this it will make your
little patties non-friable because the
whole thing
starts to separate
and then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian i like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley mint coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavours play off each other
next
two eggs
in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball
shake them like a little mini burger
you could spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes
pan on
get that nice and hot while i'm waiting
for that i'll get the dressing ready
slice the red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
season with a sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
got that sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done i can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
we get a nice crisp edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cake sizzle away i can finish off
my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
watercress it's cut off stalks
[Music]
shallot rings watercress and shallot
go brilliantly well together
the shallot looks so dainty when you
open up these little ringlets
don't forget to turn your cakes
now tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them i'll put them in the fridge
just drop those slow-cooked warm
tomatoes over the watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious
little drizzle of aged pulse milk
vinegar
gives that tartness to the watercress
watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it
and then tilt it to the side because i
want the garnish i don't want the juice
but that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night i honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
watercress salad all of the flavor with
none of the meat
[Music]
jack
here's a hand please
why
because it's your favorite
yeah chicken wings
okay
all right let's start off with the
marinade tamarind paste in first
all that into there
all of that yeah all of that okay
good
so two tablespoons of palm sugar please
don't like heated sugar um it's a really
good question it's a natural palm sugar
and it's perfect for marinades how many
wings do you think you've eaten so far
at the age of 13.
oh i eat
probably 50 a year 50 years yeah
something like that a nice sprinkle of
chilli flakes depends how hot you like
them
oh i love them hot hot uh don't forget
the girls you know they start
complaining when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food
um
i don't know i truly love hot food so in
there we've got palm sugar
tamarind paste chili flakes
some garlic one nice tablespoon
of fish sauce please
this is looking really good isn't it
and then a couple tablespoons of oil the
marinade
in
how nice a little taste
not your finger jack
that's really good right wings in get
your hands in there and start rubbing in
the marinade please okay
so the secret now is to coat
the chicken wings and all that marinade
yeah yeah
how long do you leave them in here do
you know what
the longer the better
cover that
with limb film wash your hands
excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
right so they've marinated now
if you take the tray out people
bottom one thank you and then we're
gonna put some tinfoil on there thank
you
so
pop that in half
it stops them from sticking and
that'll stop
the wings from burning so from there
get them really dipped in that marinade
and try and get the wing like that and
just sort of scoop it
look like that so get that really nice
glaze on there
and then just
yeah
so that garlic will roast
i got all those wings usually
done i can make then ready for the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes
yep good man
excellent
nice it's hot wings are in
right
to go with my ultimate southeast asian
dinner rice cooked in homemade thai
green curry paste
for the easy green curry paste roughly
chop coriander
lemongrass
green chilies
lime leaf shallots
garlic and ginger
[Music]
a glug of oil and blitz
[Music]
the paste takes minutes to make but
it'll keep for up to 10 days if covered
with oil and stored in a sealed jar in
the fridge
to awaken the flavors lime roll to
release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
[Music]
heat the paste until aromatic
add in cooled or leftover rice i love
using fragrant jasmine rice but your
standard long grain rice is great too
[Music]
when thoroughly heated through
serve
thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this it's
incredible but simply add to chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes
right now for the green beans
beans in
uh bring the water to the bowl what's
the first thing i should put in there
beans
salt so nice pinch of salt in there yeah
so make an amazing dressing two nine
tablespoons yep a bit crunchy peanut
butter please why is it crunchy it'll
give it texture
and it'll be nice and sort of chunky
green beans in okay got the rice green
beans
we're gonna blast them for two two and a
half minutes what does blanching
actually mean blanching means sort of
part cooking
okay i'm gonna blanch them in boiling
water yeah and then finish them
in the pan use the back of the spoon a
little bit easier
a teaspoon of brown sugar
and she goes
nice
is that a little bit too thick
maybe yeah it is let's put a little
touch more
soy sauce in there let it down
yeah yeah that's better
some vinegar nice
i'll get a pan on now
for my beans
so little taste did you taste it
it's so good oh man
wow so we've got the garlic like that
i'm going to slice the garlic down like
this
keep the knife
nice and flat
that way you'll slice through it
take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first just cut
it in half okay
your fingers good and then lay the flat
side down so it's nice and sturdy and
that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good i'll drain the beans
nice a little
tablespoon
of oil
get the pan nice and hot
and throw the garlic in people
good
it's nice
so first smell that already
so give that
a little task
so when you toss it push it down
push away and pull back
okay have a little go
push it down gently
take your time
nice
so push down
and pull back up that's it nice
so it's getting nice and golden brown
green beans are drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans
okay with the rice
and it's none of that
oh wow
i want you now to spoon
the dressing release and she goes
nice
how delicious does that look
wow what's daddy's policy at home no
waste no waste no waste bud
now
smell that now
oh wow
it doesn't smell like green beans it
smells like what is this oh thanks
how nice is that
lovely amazing right
that's the rice that's the green beans
now i want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please
nice and generous with a sesame seed
i'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now
all that's left for your favorites to
come out
don't those beans smell amazing yeah
um
jack look at those beauties one for me
one for you three for me
one for you
i would like you to sprinkle some spring
onions
on top please
nice and generous
transformed a very cheap and cheerful
chicken wing
yeah right you take them over please do
not drop them okay jack
let's go but
nice
[Music]
this is my ultimate simple southeast
asian dinner
sticky spicy chicken wings thai green
curry rice and fantastic beans with
chili peanut dressing guaranteed to get
the fussiest of eaters into greens
you